[Musique] la
russie dit qu'elle descend ces forces que
nous ne voyons pas se produire sur le
terrain
nos informations indiquent clairement que
ces forces,
y compris les troupes au sol, les avions, les navires
se préparent à lancer une attaque
contre l'ukraine
dans les prochains jours, d'
abord la
russie prévoit de fabriquer un prétexte
pour son attaque,
cela pourrait être un événement violent que la
russie imputera à l'ukraine ou une
accusation scandaleuse que la russie
portera contre le gouvernement ukrainien en
second lieu
en réponse à cette provocation fabriquée,
les plus hauts niveaux du gouvernement russe
peuvent convoquer théâtralement des
réunions d'urgence
pour faire face au si  -appelée crise
prochaine
l'attaque est prévue pour commencer des
missiles et des bombes russes
tomberont à travers l'ukraine les
communications seront bloquées les
cyberattaques fermeront les principales
institutions ukrainiennes
après que les
chars et les soldats russes avanceront
sur des cibles clés qui ont déjà été
identifiées et cartographiées en  plans détaillés,
nous pensons que ces objectifs  inclure
la capitale de la russie kiev la capitale de l'ukraine
une ville de 2,8 millions d'habitants
et les attaques conventionnelles
ne sont pas tout ce que la russie prévoit d'infliger
au peuple ukrainien
nous avons des informations qui indiquent que la
russie ciblera des groupes spécifiques d'
ukrainiens